depuis ma vidéo sur ces n'a plus aucune
star de télé réalité s'est remis à la
chanson ça c'est ou pas sofiane anciens
candidats de télé-réalité sort une
chanson pour déclarer sa flamme à nabila
ancienne candidate de télé-réalité et
sofiane a totalement craqué pour débiles
à nabila pardon ça crève les yeux
j'aimais déjà ton délire et des pinceaux
j'aimais déjà ton délire était façon à
adacore ah oui c'est comme ça qui les
appelle
ok d'accord délire et façon jeu je
comprends mieux que tout est plus clair
d'un coup c'est déjà rien qu'en lisant
la description de la vidéo on est
désappointé 1
le clip de l'énorme tube de sofiane
l'homme le plus modeste du monde comme
parce que énorme
ok tube oh non j'aurais plutôt dit une
énorme
apparemment la crise est passée par là
il n'y avait plus assez de budget pour
acheter du tissu choix ya tellement peu
de tissu sur nabila que la vidéo est
passé en interdits aux moins de 18 ans
sur youtube
c'est la crise c'est la crise deuxième
restriction budgétaire vous avez vu où
ils ont tourné leur frein
sous la douche ouais c'est la crise mais
pourquoi pas bon cela dit il m'aurait
demandé de faire le clip
je vais même aller encore plus loin
tadam de monthois nam nam et là c'est
sûr pour le rideau c'est être un peu
inquiète je sais bull doit laver laver
l'attendait il faut écouter les paroles
aussi c'est exceptionnel j'ai jamais
entendu ça de ma vie j'ai maté se
brouille qui valait de l'or monté comme
un buisson monté comme un piston t bonds
déjà paye ta modestie et ensuite ils
espèrent séduire une fille en disant ça
exceptionnel
tu sais débit là quand je pense à toi je
fais normalement lorsque j'ai un très
gros piston donc disais-je de toi voilà
des choses qui arrivent et surtout
grande première dans la chanson sofiane
le premier chanteur bègue est pourri
pourrait faire changer changer
lors d'un bouton colombo démêler
pression
un chanteur bègue marmol tu étais sûr
que je peux je chante et ça va pas ddt
ranger non t'inquiète pas dit nabil à
pourvoir
nabil nabila nabila nabi nabila bon ok
fais comme tu le sens ok je suis en pole
paul paul paul pole position et
j'aimerais terminer en disant que je
respecte nabila pour sa patience moi ça
me saoule rec on écorche mon nom pendant
quatre minutes non-stop
non c'est juste juste nabila mais là
c'est pas nabi nabila c'est juste nabil
abu dhabi au début nabila à ce que je
dit sophie sofian non juste nabila tu
rajoute encore un avis je te pète la
gueule à chaque fois que vous partagez
cette vidéo la villa se fait refaire une
partie de son corps on verra combien de
temps il faudra avant qu'elle se
transforme en plastique une minute ou
deux bah si tu veux voir mes hôtes vie
des vidéos sur cyprien point fr fr oui
d'accord je sais pas chanter mais c'est
pas grave